- So, you're not gonna solve it
with this incredibly costly
and very, very
ineffective policy.
The way you're gonna solve it
is like we've solved
all other problems.
Through innovation.
Remember back in the 1950s,
Los Angeles was a
terribly polluted place.
It was mostly because of cars
and a geological, you know,
it put in a basin and stuff.
But fundamentally, the point
was not to tell everyone
in Los Angeles, "I'm sorry,
could you walk instead?"
Which would never have worked.
- They do not walk in LA.
- No, you're not gonna
take people's cars away.
The solution was this, you know,
tiny technological advance
called the catalytic converter
innovated in 1978.
You pluck it on
the end tailpipe,
and then you can drive much
longer and pollute much less.
Yeah, it costs a
couple hundred dollars,
but you've actually
managed to convince
almost everyone across the
world this is a good idea,
and it solved a very large
portion of the problem.
Likewise, the US is the country
that's cut most
emissions, CO2 emissions,
over the last 10 years.
How?
Not because of Obama or Trump,
but because of fracking.
You basically, inadvertently,
made gas so much cheaper
that most people switched
from coal to gas,
and gas emits about half
as much CO2 as coal.
So you solved a large part
of the climate problem
through innovation.
That's how we do it.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the president of the
Copenhagen Consensus,
an author of "Best Things First:
The 12 Most Efficient Solutions
For the World's Poorest
and Our Global SDG
Promises," Bjorn Lomborg.
Welcome back to
"The Rubin Report."
- Hey, it's great to be here.
- Bjorn, I checked
right before we started.
It's been over two years,
which is absolutely crazy since
the last time that we spoke.
I don't know how that happened,
but I do know that in these
two years, the climate people,
the catastrophization people
have all increasingly
gone crazier.
But before we dissect them,
for the people that
may not know you,
can you gimme a one minute bio
on what gets you to doing
all the things you're doing,
and writing a book like this,
and then we'll
take it from there.
- Sure, what I focus on
is really to say, look,
we don't have unlimited funds,
we have limited resources,
but there's so many
things we'd like to do.
Why don't we focus on
where we can spend money,
and do the most good first?
That's both true for climate,
so let's do the smart stuff
and not the stupid
stuff in climate,
but it's also true for all
the other world's problems.
Remember, we promised,
you know, to fix hunger,
and poverty, and education,
and all the other
problems in the world,
and what this book really
does is try to say,
"There's some amazingly smart
policies that we can do.
Let's do those first."
Whatever else you'd love to
do, let's spend money on that.
But let's just get
those, you know,
it's about $35 billion
globally, and make the world
an impressively
much better place.
- Right, so basically, I
mean, the thesis of the book,
you think for about
35 billion, we can fix
pretty much the major stuff.
I assume by your background
there that you think
some of this includes
just some plants
you could probably
get at Home Depot
to keep the air in
your house clean, huh?
- Please give me
more plants, yeah.
No, so we're not gonna
fix all problems,
but we're gonna fix a
majority of problems,
and what we are
essentially showing is
and we worked with
more than a hundred
of the world's top economists
and several Nobel Laureates
to try to find out what
do we already know works.
And what we find is,
for $35 billion a year.
That's not nothing.
I mean, I think you have it.
I certainly don't have
it, but, you know-
- I'm doing all right, but
that might be pushing it.
- Yes, look, in the
global setting of things,
that is really couch change.
For $35 billion a year, we
could save 4.2 million people
from dying each and every year,
and we could make the
poor half of the world
about $1.1 trillion better off.
This is probably
the very best thing
we could do for the world,
and that's why I'm saying
let's at least do those
best things first.
- And that's also
why you're a bit
of a controversial character
because you're trying to give
solutions that are different
than what seem to be the
solutions given to us by say,
the WEF, and the UN, and much
of our western governments,
and all that.
So I wanna spend most
of this conversation
talking about those
solutions, but I thought
why don't we get some of
the people and organizations
out of the way that are
causing the problems?
Like, when you see the
WEF and the 2030 Project,
all of these things, the Green
New Deal here in America,
all of these giant expenditures
that will massively
change things,
do you look at them all
as sort of these are just
complete nonsensical
boondoggle pipe dreams
that will never work?
Like, is there anything good,
is there any good nugget
in any of these things?
- Well, first of all,
there's the amazing good
that actually shows that a
lot of people want to do good.
They really want to
be part of something
that makes the world better.
Now, there is a real problem
with many of the things they
identify, but very often,
it ends up being a
very ineffective way
to try to tackle the problem.
You know, take heat waves,
which is in the
conversation right now.
Yes, we're gonna
see more heat waves
because of climate change,
and climate change
is a real problem,
but we need to get a
sense of proportion.
First of all, remember
many, many more people
die from cold and from heat,
and so we also need to remember
to actually help all the
people who suffer from cold,
which is mostly about getting
them cheap energy access.
But also if you
wanna help the people
who are suffering from
more heat, and we should,
it's mostly about getting sure
people access to
air conditioning,
it's about having them get cheap
electricity, and of course,
also make cities more livable.
One of the ways
you could do that
is by making greener,
making more water features,
making them lighter.
Los Angeles and many other
cities are, you know,
experimenting with painting
the rooftops white,
or painting the tarmac white,
and that reflects a
lot of the energy away
and actually makes these
cities much cooler.
The point here is those
sorts of solutions
will actually help right
now at very low cost,
and help real people.
Whereas much of the
argument that you have
with these, you know, we
should all go net zero
will have huge costs.
We're talking
five, $10 trillion.
This is more than what
most countries spend
on education or even healthcare.
And even if you did
it, it would only mean
that temperatures would
rise, but not quite as much.
That's no way to help people.
So my point here is to say,
let's focus on the smart
solution that'll actually help.
- Right, and I think
one of the problems is,
as I often play clips
of these people,
the elites who seem to be
pushing a lot of these policies
and, you know, they don't
want you to have your stove,
and they're, you know,
they don't want you
to have this hot water heater
or whatever it might be.
We know they're on
their private jets
and all of these
things, and by the way,
I don't begrudge them
any of those things
except for the fact that
they're trying to make sure
none of us get
those luxury items.
But when you say, and I quote,
"Climate change is real,"
I know a certain amount of
my audience is gonna go,
"Wait a minute, we've just
had it even hearing that"
because they're so upset
by hearing John Kerry,
and they're so upset by
watching Leonardo DiCaprio
act one way on his
yacht and helicopter,
and then preach another way.
So when you say
climate change is real,
what do you actually
mean by that?
Meaning that obviously
the climate is changing,
but do you mean manmade,
and how much of that
is something that we
can actually affect?
- So again, I work
with economists
so we're looking at what
are the smart solutions.
I have read, unlike I think
a lot of people, almost all.
I don't advise anyone to do
that, it's very, very boring.
But all of the UN
climate panel reports,
and they're reasonably
sensible all the way through.
They really tried to tell you
what is the best
scientific evidence,
and the short version is
we're pumping out more CO2
mostly from fossil fuels.
CO2 is one of the many
greenhouse gases that trap heat
and make the world
a little bit warmer.
This, all other things equal,
is going to make more problems
than it's gonna make solutions
simply because we built
our entire society
on what the temperature was
the last hundred, 200 years.
If it got colder, or
if it gets warmer,
which is probably gonna be
because of global warming,
that will incur a cost.
This is not the end of the world
as it's being, you know, sold.
It is a problem.
So economists and the
only climate economist
to win the Nobel Prize,
William Nordhouse,
estimate that by the end of
the century, if we do nothing,
which is stupid and
we shouldn't do,
and probably is implausible,
but even if we did nothing,
the cost by the end of the
century would be equivalent
to losing about 4% of our GDP.
Now remember, by then
we'll be much richer.
The UN estimate we'll
be about 450% richer
as rich as we are today.
So what this really means is
because of global warming,
if we do nothing,
it will feel like
we'll only be 434% as rich
by the end of the century
rather than 450.
That's not the end of the world.
That's a problem, and
that's why I'm saying,
look, if it's the
end of the world,
of course you should spend
everything to fix it,
but that's not what this is.
It's a problem, and
we should spend money
smartly on this problem,
but also remember
there are lots of other problems
that are much bigger
for most people.
- So before we get to some of
those specific 12 solutions,
what would you say to the people
who are just sort of skeptical
that we can do
anything about this?
Meaning like, so
from an American
perspective, for example,
that we're so sort
of inefficient,
our politics is so broken,
these people can't
build a road properly,
or at least in a
cost effective way,
that the idea that they could
solve any of these things
is completely crazy,
and then you hear people
like AOC say, you know,
"We only have 12
years left on Earth."
I think that was
about three years ago,
so now we've got
nine, and it's like,
if you think AOC can solve
any of your problems,
much less solve climate
problems, you know,
I got a bridge to sell you.
- So I think a lot of
the intuition is right
that we are essentially
embarking on something
that's gonna be so
phenomenally costly
that most countries are actually
not going to deliver on this.
I live in the EU, I
actually worry a little bit.
The EU is so good
at doing stuff,
they promised that we
might actually do it
despite the fact that it's
gonna be phenomenally costly.
But certainly, in the US
and most other places,
you'll simply elect
other politicians
really start hurting.
Now, that's how, you know,
how democracies work,
and that's probably really good.
So you're not gonna solve it
with this incredibly costly
and very, very
ineffective policy.
The way you're gonna solve it
is like we've solved
all other problems.
Through innovation.
Remember back in the 1950s,
Los Angeles was a
terribly polluted place.
It was mostly because of cars
and a geological, you know,
put in a basin and stuff.
But fundamentally, the point
was not to tell everyone
in Los Angeles, "I'm sorry,
could you walk instead?"
Which would never
have worked, right?
- They do not walk in LA.
- No, you're not gonna
take people's cars away.
The solution was this, you
know, tiny technological advance
called the catalytic
converter innovated in 1978.
You pluck it on
the end tailpipe,
and then you can drive much
longer and pollute much less.
Yeah, it costs a
couple hundred dollars,
but you've actually
managed to convince
almost everyone across the
world this is a good idea,
and it solved a very large
portion of the problem.
Likewise, the US is the country
that's cut most
emissions, CO2 emissions,
over the last 10 years.
How?
Not because of Obama or Trump,
but because of fracking.
You basically, inadvertently,
made gas so much cheaper
that most people switched
from coal to gas,
and gas emits about half
as much CO2 as coal.
So you solved a large part
of the climate problem
through innovation.
That's how we do it.
Remember, if we can
innovate green energy
to be cheaper than fossil
fuels, everyone will switch.
Not rich, well-meaning
Americans or Europeans,
but also the Chinese, the
Indians, and the Africans
who are gonna be emitting most
of the CO2 in this century.
So I totally get your
viewers', you know,
sort of reluctance.
We are trying to solve
this very ineffectively
and incredibly expensively,
which probably means
we won't solve it at all,
but there is a smart way,
and it's called innovation.
Just like most other things.
- Well, that's exactly why
I wanted to have you
on because I know
even for me in the last year
especially as I've watched
so many of these
globalist organizations
with these crazy projects,
and then the hypocrisy,
and literally the gas stove
thing here in America,
all of this nonsense, even
I have become more skeptical
in a way that I don't
wanna be blindly skeptical.
I wanna be skeptical with some
knowledge of what's going on,
which is exactly
why we have you on.
So let's talk about
some of those solutions
because you lay out
these 12 solutions.
So give me some, what's
like the easiest thing
that we can start doing now
probably some of which
we're doing to some degree?
- So I'll tell you two.
You know, it's asking, I
have 12 great solutions.
You're asking me to
pick my favorite child.
I'm not gonna do
that, but, you know,
but I'm gonna give you two.
One is to save lives.
So one thing that I think
most people don't recognize
is that each year,
tuberculosis still kills
1.4, 1.5 million people.
Last year it was bigger
again than COVID.
You know, COVID
took the top place
for infectious disease
killer in 2020 and '21,
but otherwise, it's
been tuberculosis.
We in the rich world fixed this
more than half a century ago.
But if you actually go back,
tuberculosis was
a terrible killer.
This is why, you know,
Sabine and Moulin Rouge
died from tuberculosis,
and a fourth of everyone
who lived in the 1800s
in Europe and the US
died from tuberculosis.
This was a terrible killer.
It killed probably
about a billion people
over the last 200 years, but
we figured out a way to do it.
Now we don't have a problem,
but most poor countries
is not that place,
and there's a very simple way.
It's unfortunately one of the
reasons why it's hard to do.
You actually have to take your
medication for half a year,
and most people
know that it's hard
to just take your
medication for two weeks.
But there's a lot of ways
to, you know, sort of gamify,
get sort of
tuberculosis anonymous
where everybody gets together
once a month and say,
"Yes, I took my my medication
all the way through,"
and, you know, you
gamify it and give people
a carton of orange juice,
that kind of thing.
And it may seem a little weird
that you have to pay people
to do it, but if you do that,
if you make sure that they
don't have tuberculosis,
they don't pass it on to
another 10 to 20 people,
and this is how we solve
much of the problem.
You also need to screen
many more people.
We've investigated and there's
lots of models that show
how much is this gonna cost.
It's probably gonna cost
about $6 billion a year.
So again, not nothing,
but we can save
almost a million
people from dying
over the next half
century every year.
So this is one of the
things where we say,
and, you know, we're
slightly crude economists.
We go in and say,
"How much will it cost
and how much good will it do?"
So we give you a
benefit cost ratio.
We try to estimate for
every dollar spent,
how much good will
you end up doing?
Turns out, if you do
on tuberculosis for
every dollar spent,
you'll do $46 of social good.
That's just an
incredible opportunity.
- So do you guys bring
these ideas to say,
a guy like Bill Gates,
who's got the billions,
who seemingly wants to help,
you know, by his own words,
would say he wants to
help the people of Africa
and help the world?
Do you bring these ideas to
them, and then what do they say?
- Yes, so we both
talked to Bill Gates.
Actually, the Gates Foundation
paid for this project.
But we talked to Bill Gates,
I wrote an op-ed
together with him.
We talked to USAID and
other organizations,
but crucially we
also talk to a lot
of poor country
governments who obviously
should also pony up
some of this money
because it's their own
citizens who are dying,
and much of this
is they're dying
because they're
not the, you know,
they're not the rich people
in the poor part of the world,
if you're rich in the
poor part of the world,
you don't get tuberculosis,
and even if you do,
you don't die from it.
But, you know, the
slum populations,
it's the migrant
populations, it's the minors,
it's the prison
populations, but the problem
is this percolate all the
way through societies.
So we try to take all
of these arguments,
and make people aware that
here's a very cheap way
to make the world
much, much better.
And yes, they say, "Oh,
that's really interesting."
Now they're not gonna say, oh
sure, so here's $6 billion.
Make it go away, Bjorn.
First of all, that's
not what I do.
I'm an academic.
I wouldn't know what
to do with 6 billion.
And there's a lot
of organizations
that are actually
really good at this.
So you should give it to your
national healthcare systems,
and the, you know,
Stop TB Campaign,
and many others in
those countries.
But the point is, we're
trying to make it easier
for politicians, and
for philanthropists,
and for development
organizations to spend right,
to spend it where
it really matters.
- So all right, before
we get to that second one
that you like outta these 12,
and then we'll get to
as many as possible,
how do you make sure that
the mechanisms are in place
that these things
just don't become
what seemingly most
government things become,
which are giant, you know,
government waste projects?
We give money to everybody,
we never get
receipts on anything.
I think that that's another
thing that a lot of people
are worried about these days.
Like, even if you can convince
them of some of the risks
and why we can do
some good things,
they're just like, ah, you know,
we're just gonna pour
money, and maybe it'll work,
maybe it won't, but
we just won't know.
- And that's a very
correct concern,
and a lot of the things
that we spend money on
go to things that
make you feel good,
things that look good on TV,
but have very little effect.
But we are actually using
the best models of things
that have already been
done where we showcase,
look, if you spend
the money here,
even though some of it
is gonna go to waste,
you know, that's probably true
almost everywhere in the world,
and some of it is just gonna
be spent in competently.
That's just the way
the world works.
We've taken that
into our calculation,
so we're not assuming
that this is gonna be
heroically spent in the
very best possible way.
It's gonna be spent
reasonably competently.
Like, you know, you
would actually hope
you can reasonably do this.
And let me share this
because it's much clearer
with the other proposal
I was gonna talk about,
namely education.
Education is something
everyone agrees both sucks,
and we should do much
more about, right?
But it especially sucks in
the poor part of the world.
So there's almost half a
billion kids in primary school
in the poor part of the world.
We got almost all
kids in school.
That's great, but they're
learning virtually nothing.
We say that they
technically learn to read,
but if you ask
'em this question,
so you ask 'em to
read this question,
this is a 10 year old, right?
VJ has a red hat, blue
shirt, and yellow shoes.
What color is the hat?
It's red, right?
But 80%-
- I got it, I got it.
- Thank you. Thank you.
So you're there.
80% of kids cannot
answer this question,
and it's not because
they're dumb.
It's because they
can't actually string
all these words together
into a meaningful sentence,
and of course that
means we've technically
taught them to read, but
they can't actually use it
to become more productive,
and become richer,
and more resilient and do
all the wonderful things.
It is that they haven't actually
learned most of the stuff.
So what we find is you should
spend more money on education,
but this is exactly
where you would say,
"Oh, but there's a lot of
ways you can spend it badly,"
and that's absolutely true.
So one example that I give
in the book is Indonesia,
and, you know,
bless their hearts,
they really wanna do good.
They basically said, "We
care so much about education
that we're gonna double
spending on education."
So they ended up hiring more
than a million new teachers,
they doubled the pay for
each of these teachers,
and because of the
way they did it.
So they did it in different
regions at different times,
there's actually big study
that could sort of look this
as a pseudo-random trial
where you could see,
well, how much good does this
actually do for the schools?
And it turns out,
this famous paper
is called Double for Nothing,
and it basically shows
yes, you spent
twice as much money,
and there was no impact
whatsoever on teaching.
It's very, very easy to spend
money badly on education,
and this is true
everywhere else.
But what we identify
are three great ways
that are very, very well tested.
I'm just gonna tell
you one of 'em.
So the problem in most schools,
but especially in
poor countries,
is you have 50 kids
in this one, you know,
in this fourth grade.
They're all 12 years old,
but they have wildly
different abilities.
You know, some of 'em are
far ahead of the teacher,
some of 'em have virtually
no clue what's going on,
and what's a teacher gonna do?
He's gonna try to teach
somewhere in the middle,
and, you know, some
kids are gonna be bored,
lots of kids are
gonna be totally lost.
He should teach each
one of these kids
at his or her own level, but
of course you can't do that
if you have 50 kids.
But if you put each of these
kids in front of a tablet
with educational software,
just one hour a day,
this tablet, actually
the software,
will very quickly figure out
where exactly are you on this?
You know, are you really
ahead of this curve or not?
And teach you at
your exact level.
So the rest of the
school will still be
this boring old school
where most people,
kids will be lost or
bored, but one hour a day,
they'll actually learn.
And what it turns out, and
there's lots of evidence
that for $21 a year per student,
they're not gonna
get the tablet,
it's gonna be shared
with a lot of other kids
and all that stuff, and
you also need, you know,
solar panels in places where
they don't have electricity,
you need a locker for the tablet
so they don't get
stolen and all this,
but it actually turns
out that for every year
they go to school,
they will now learn
three years of schooling.
Now it's still
pretty bad schooling,
so it's not like phenomenal.
They're not gonna be
Einsteins just from this,
but this is a way that
we can actually make
almost half a
billion kids smarter,
and what that means
is that they will
when they become adults, go
out and be much more productive
and actually make their
nations much richer,
and of course that
will solve a lot
of the other problems they have.
So we estimate this will cost
globally about $10 billion.
So again, not nothing,
but it will actually
generate benefits worth $600
billion each and every year.
This is just amazing
and astounding.
So instead of spending it badly,
we should spend it on this
really, really effective way.
- You know, it's funny, I'm
reminded of a "Simpsons" episode
from probably around 1993
where Bart is
struggling in school.
So they put him in
the slower class,
and then he looks at the teacher
in the slower class and goes,
"Let me get this straight.
I'm struggling in
the other class,
so now you've put me
in a slower class.
How does this make any
sense to you people?"
So you're trying to solve that.
Okay, so it seems like between
education and tuberculosis,
if my math is correct,
we're at about 16 billion,
which is about half
of what you need
to fix some of the problems.
So we've got about eight
or nine minutes left.
Let's plow through
a couple others,
let's get to that 32.
- Tell you one other, so
one that I think amazed me
is the fact that maternity,
and especially pregnancy,
and especially birth,
is terribly dangerous.
So it turns out
about 300,000 moms
die each year around pregnancy,
and about 2.3 million kids
die in the first 28 days
in their life on Earth.
- [Dave] Wow.
- And this is not rocket
science how we deal with this.
This is simply about getting
the women into facilities,
so about two thirds of them
give birth in facilities.
We need to get like 90%
of 'em into facilities,
and these facilities
need to have
basic emergency obstetric care.
This is something the
World Health Organization,
lots of institutions have shown.
What will that take?
You know, it's about having,
I don't know, disinfectant.
You would imagine that
would be sort of obvious,
but actually a lot of 'em
don't have clean water
so that you can wash
down the surfaces,
but it's also something
so simple as it turns out
that about 700,000
kids each year die
because they never
start to breath.
So they come out, you
know, they're given birth,
but then they don't
start breathing.
Now this also happened
in rich countries,
so about 80% of all kids that
come out of the mom, you know,
just start breathing right away.
15% need this slap in
the back to get going,
but the last 5% don't, and,
you know, in the rich world,
of course, we just simply
put a mask over their mouth
and put positive air pressure,
put it into their lungs,
and they go (inhales deeply).
And then they go, and
then we save them.
But we don't have
that in about half
of all the poor
parts of the world.
This hand pump costs what, $75?
And it could probably
save 25 lives
over its three year life period.
That's the kind of thing.
So there's a whole
list of things.
This will cost about
$5 billion again,
but it will save 166,000 moms
from dying each and every
year, and it will save
1.2 million kids
each and every year.
How are we not doing that?
So, you know, that's
another amazing thing
actually every dollar spent
will deliver $87 worth of good.
So there's malaria.
- Yeah, you've got me to, I
see about 21 million so far.
We're getting there.
- So, and of course
I'm telling you
the sort of more
expensive stuff first
because they're the
really big things.
Malaria is actually
it used to be a huge
problem around the world.
It's no longer,
it's just in Africa.
There's a lot of
reasons for that,
but we know how to fix it.
It's simply giving
out more of these
insecticide treated bed nets
so people will sleep
under these nets.
They both physically make sure
that the mosquitoes can't
come in and bite you,
and it also kills 'em off
because as insecticide.
It is very effective,
very simple treatment.
It'll cost about
$1.1 billion a year,
and it will save about 300,000
people each and every year.
Again, a fantastic investment.
One other thing that I think
you'll find
incredibly interesting
is agricultural research
and development.
So, you know, we
worry about the fact
that people don't
have enough food.
We also have part, I'm not
gonna tell you about that,
we also talk about how we
can get better food to kids,
but it turns out a lot of that
is very corruption prone, right?
If you spend a lot
of money on food,
a lot of people will see
that, for instance, in India,
a lot of merchants will
sell you really bad food
and then you try to
distribute for free
and nobody really wants it
because it tastes
terrible kind of thing.
So the best way to
deal with this is to,
just like we talked about
before with climate, innovation.
We've had a green revolution
back in the '60s and '70s
which basically meant
that we could produce
maybe twice as much food
on the same acre of land,
which is a great innovation.
You just simply make the
seed much more productive.
We need that for all the stuff
they grow in the poor
part of the world.
So that's sorghum, and
cassava, and all these things
that you probably
haven't heard of,
but we need the same
green revolution there.
We estimate this would cost
about $5.5 billion a year,
but it would generate
much more food,
but that would both means
the price would be lower
for people who
live in the cities,
but it would mean that the
farmers could produce much more
so the farmers would
also get richer.
Everyone would win,
and we'd avoid about
a hundred million people
starving each and every year.
- Going on that for a moment,
how much tension do you see
between big cities and
rural areas these days?
You know, I was in Cali before
where there was always
this incredible tension
between say Los
Angeles where I was.
Obviously you have, you
know, 8 million people,
something like that in
a relatively small area.
Then you have the whole
north of the state,
which is all the agricultural,
and they were always
fighting for more water.
The people of LA
wanted the water.
Just the general like day-to-day
living of who gets what.
- Oh, and look, cities get
a lot more money everywhere
because that's where,
you know, the power is,
that's where the
politicians live,
that's, you know, who runs
the media and everything else.
And so in that sense,
what we try to pick up
is a lot of the great
investments are in poorer areas
because that's where you can
save people really cheaply.
So one thing is, for instance,
more childhood immunization,
and that's especially about
so we got about
80, 90% vaccinated
most places around the world.
You know, measles for instance.
Great idea, don't skimp on your
measles vaccination, right?
It's just a terribly
deadly disease
that used to kill about 800,000,
now we're down to 80,000.
But you still need to get
more people vaccinated
otherwise you're gonna
get these epidemics again.
And getting the last
ones out in the sticks
is gonna be more expensive.
But even then we find with
a much more expensive cost,
it's gonna cost about...
Sorry, I'm just
looking at the cost
'cause I can't
just remember them.
$1.7 billion a year,
but it's gonna save
about half a million
kids each and every year.
So the benefit cost
rate is about 101.
So again, we try to
identify different things
that are incredibly good.
We simply said we're gonna
identify the best buys,
and we put the bar at
15, which is, you know,
somewhat arbitrary,
but is, you know,
something our Nobels did.
Just simply for saying, look,
these are the so no-brainers
that everybody should just agree
this is something
we should be doing.
- How worried are you when
you talk about vaccines now
because of everything that
happened with COVID, you know,
these bells go off in
my head about vaccines,
and how they get
in people's arms,
and the pharmaceutical
companies, you know,
they have no ability to be sued.
All of these things that
now people are skeptical
of things, say,
a measles vaccine
that really very few
people were skeptical of
say five years ago.
Now you just say vaccine and
now it's setting off bells
on people that have
long been dormant.
- And that's a terrible outcome,
and the way I try to treat it
is to talk about
childhood immunization.
We're not talking
about, you know,
we should do another
COVID vaccine,
which obviously is hugely
sort of divisive, divisive?
- Either way, I'll go with you.
- Okay, yeah, but, you
know, childhood vaccines
everyone know have just saved
an enormous amount of kids.
Obviously, the fact
that we could vaccinate
against smallpox, which,
you know, just last century
actually killed
somewhere between
300 and 500 million people,
and we eradicated it in 1978.
There's no more
smallpox in the world.
This probably every
year saves what,
four or 5 million
people from dying?
That's just a fantastic outcome.
This is true for measles
and many of these
other simple diseases.
This is not rocket science.
This is something we know.
So we need to sort of
get over ourselves,
and our worry about...
And I think, you know, I see
the correct conversation about
to what extent did we do right
in the priorities on COVID,
and that's for a whole
different kind of conversation.
But we know that this works
for childhood immunization,
and that's what
we're arguing for.
- Bjorn, if my math is correct,
we got to about 26 billion,
but unfortunately
we're out of time,
but I will have you back on soon
to continue this discussion
'cause I think it's important
to get between the skepticism,
and the ability to do
things functionally
that will actually
make our lives better.
That's what you're all about.
We'll link to the
book down below,
and it was good to see you.
- Thank you. Likewise.
- If you wanna
find out precisely
when the world is going to end,
check out our
environment playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a wide variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notifiable
future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.